good morning
Millennials welcome back to the chosen
happy Thursday hope everybody's have an
amazing beautiful setting and smart day
speaking of beautiful standing and smart
it's jackieo hello shc fet how are you
today hey L delay I'm doing well are we
going to be honest we're going to be
honest that no Jackie let's lie really
even though we said on the show today SL
yesterday that we were recording this on
Wednesday okay okay it's Wednesday CL
we're authentic to a fault you know this
I know like why can't we just pre-record
our episodes without like word vomiting
like okay it's not Thursday you caught
us but it there's nothing to catch like
again we need to remind ourselves it's
our show it's our rules no and we're
like kind of constantly putting this
pressure on ourselves and we really need
to stop yeah like we can make the our
own rules we can record anytime we want
as long as the episode drops and you
know what else we get what we want and
this winter break we want Jordan also I
feel like it is germine to the episode
episode that we be brutally honest about
the time of day because I do think that
it affects the episode I do no I'm not
going to lie when we pre-record episodes
it doesn't happen a lot but every now
and then you know Jackie and I aren't
available in the morning so the night
before we'll record the episode for that
day it barely ever ever ever happens but
sometimes it does and we I think are
like the craziest during those episodes
no not even crazy necessarily just
different you know the day has taken its
toll on us we've been through stuff and
I feel like every morning when we do the
toast you ask me like Hi how are you
like what's going on and I completely
forget what I did the day before like
tabul laasa every day why are you doing
your makeup and not listening to me oh
I'm sorry I'm not doing my makeup I'm
not doing my makeup let me tell you cuz
you know no you know my lash lift is my
new personality um they gave me these
little spoolies they say always you know
try and brush every morning and night so
I just forgot and the spoolie was
sitting right here I'm 100% listening
I'm just brushing my lashes you're going
to have to tell your spoolie that you
can't brush right now because you're
busy spool I have to go bye yeah I'm
sorry you were saying I was saying that
usually in the mornings like I don't
remember what I did the day before tabul
rasa but now like I remember what I did
today oh I remember it's still very in
the front of my mind I recorded the
redheads today which will be up on
Thursday but the episode was so long
because the this Thursday today today so
you guys you have to talk to people like
it's Thursday okay episode is going to
be is up today it might not be up
already I don't know about that because
I have to edit four people's audios I
think we recorded for like an hour 30
I'm going to bring it down but there was
there's a lot to edit because I want to
shorten a little bit and that's going to
take me a few hours and it's already 9
o' and I haven't started so yeah
gorilla's busy anyways new episode of
the redheads coming at
you and that was a major key major key
of my day today SL yesterday a major key
of my day yesterday today is the dresser
arrived look it's right behind me you
could see yeah having a dresser is so
lifechanging especially when your
clothes have just been in in piles on
the floor like where the dresser would
have been the dresser is now here and my
drawers are filled with my underwear and
my leggings and I just feel so good
about it I'm so happy for you it's so
nice to have a dresser I have a dresser
but without a dresser it's not the right
dresser for me living without a dresser
less than living with a dresser that's
profound was that Socrates how do you
pronounce the word d r a w e
r depends what part of the country I'm
in drawers no come on
drawers what's the other way it's like a
really like it's a it's a bad word like
they should have had something better is
it is a bad word I was saying it I said
it to Harry like the other day or today
and I remember feeling like that's kind
of a confusing word
drawer drawer like what the hell yeah
like I kind of wished what I was talking
about like had another word because I
just feel like that's a hard word for a
child oh definitely it's a hard word for
me and I'm you say and also it's like I
I'm pretty sure I draw is what I do with
my crayons not right and the kids are
they know they know draw like draw like
color not where I keep my clothes and
this one book that we read um it's like
the sequel to The gringe it's like and
he drew Drew Drew Drew and it's like oh
Drew and draw in my
drawers and then drawers is like your
underwear right it's like the Grinch
Drew and that's also where my I keep my
pajamas yeah the word draw is like a
dresser to color underwear like why does
it have so many
meanings I don't know um not that great
mistake mistake God another thing that I
was thinking cuz tonight I was reading
the book The Rainbow Fish have you read
that book recently you mean last last
night you were reading the book The
Rainbow Fish last night we were Reading
Rainbow Fish and of course it's a
classic because it's with the colorful
scales with the colorful scales obsessed
but I hadn't read it obviously in
decades and I couldn't have told you
what the storyline was but I'm finding
it to be a little
problematic why what's what's it about
rainbow fish is overp party so basically
there's a fish in the sea that's rainbow
fish and he is the most beautiful fish
in the sea and he has the scales that
are shiny and like one day a little fish
comes and asks him for a scale and he's
like no like go away scram are he rude
yeah but and he also like doesn't have
friends cuz he's like so beautiful and
he just kind of like floats around does
he not have friends because like
everybody makes fun of him or cuz he's a
dick no they want him to play with them
I think but he's just like too beautiful
like he's just like too into himself and
then someone asked him for a scale and
he was like No And then he had no
friends and he was a big loser and he
was lonely so they said like go see the
octopus like she's like the wise puss
and the octopus say that's obviously
you're by the way in this if we ever did
like a toast adaptation of rainbow fish
like you are the wise octopus and I am
the egotistical fish but I no I don't
like love her advice cuz she said that
you should give away your shiny
scales and so the book like he goes and
he gives a scale to everyone he's he's
left with zero scales and I and then
he's happy and he has friends and I just
felt like the message is kind of like
you have to dull your shine in order no
okay this is so problematic no so
problematic one yes do your shine
clearly that's a message that's being
spread but also like Why Can't This Book
teach kids like if you have something of
value whether it's Beauty smarts
whatever it is like to be gracious yeah
like you could still play with them and
and be nice and it was also like giving
like a little bit of Communism it's like
this one fish everybody gets my scales
yeah I have to distribute my scales
equally and also at the end I don't even
think he had one
scale no this is dumb I I found it to be
extremely problematic rainbow fish is
overp party I I could get behind that #
rainbow fishes over party and I was
reading and I was like where is this
going is this a good thing that he's
giving away his skills I feel like he's
ding his shine sure he was a little bit
of a prick but there are other ways
without taking away the thing that makes
you special so that I feel happens a lot
with like children's books like I
remember the first time as a somewhat
like a conscious adult that I went back
and reread the giving tree which was my
favorite book oh my God you could cry
from this book it's so sad and pathetic
like it's heartbreaking why are we
reading that should be called the Nish
Vaga the Nish
Vaga okay that's another Yiddish word
that we've I don't think ever use such a
good word it's like a a
thankless yeah like wait hold on um
oh it is really hard to describe Yiddish
words especially ones that have like
matriculated that's the thing about
Yiddish that's why it slaps so hard
because they don't have direct
translations that's why we go to these
words okay I'm looking up Nish Vaga but
like it's how do you how would you even
spell Nish
Vaga let me try what like vagina
Nish
yish no it's like not coming
up yeah it's like a it's honestly you
know what it is Jacky it's a thoughtless
little
pig yeah yeah yeah that's what Alex
Baldwin was trying to say the Nish
forgiving tree the Nish forgiving tree
that
title but how do you spell it the n i h
space in this in this context it would
be v a g i v i n g the Nish V Giving
Tree unless it's Nish
F the classic FV swap the Classic swap
Nish faga
yish that's also like one of the great
things about having um like a lot of
Jewish friends is like I feel like the
Yiddish words Yiddish for those who
don't know is a is a lost language it's
not really spoken um but you know the
Jews of your brought it with them to the
States and it's slowly lost whatever but
every family like has their own Jewish I
mean Yiddish phrases that um like never
that stayed with them that trickled down
but that doesn't mean they're like
everybody knows the mainstream ones like
you know HS and mench and schitz like
everybody knows the classic ones but
every family like has their own that
like I honestly feel like are made up um
and then like you go to someone else's
house and they're using yish phrases
like you don't know them and every now
and then you have like a crossover I was
just with Abe I was telling him about
how we always use the word
frosk that's a good one he had never
heard it and he his his family is like
very yish very ashkenas and he was like
what's a frosk and I'm like oh you know
you give a
frosk a frosk is like a hit a big slap
like a frosk no but it also could be
like you know like a a punch or an elbow
it's not necessarily like a slap
it's a frosk yeah no in our house like
if you wanted to use it in a sentence
you would always say like and I gave him
such a
frosk that's not a
sentence oh I didn't mean in a sentence
I just meant like you know shut up okay
yeah also if you do not know Yiddish is
a combination of Hebrew and a a an
amalgamation of like Eastern European
langues so it is
um that's what it is and yeah that's
what our ancestors the it's very Fiddler
on the Roof yeah it was also a lot of it
was genocided in the Holocaust so we yes
we take what we can get but yeah it's
like passed down it's the language of
our old country but I do want to say
I've I've known Yiddish like my whole
life as a language I obviously I don't
speak it I know phrases I had never
heard anybody um speak it like
conversationally until a few years ago
where I went to it was actually like a
really special event where like we got
to hear this woman speak who was like a
a scholar of yish Lang language which
all most people there's probably like 15
in the whole world M um and she like
started to read a poem like a famous
yish poem and when I tell you she
sounded so weird like I could
not stop laughing like she literally
said like AB like it's like she speak it
was literally J
brush because it's like she's speaking
Hebrew wrong she's speaking polish wrong
she speaking German wrong it doesn't
sound right because it's I felt like I
was back in high school like giggling in
the back of the classroom like I
couldn't stop laughing so funny did you
know that I took a college course called
yish and I feel like that is underrated
and more colleges should offer it and I
got so much out of it and it's such a
cool class MH and it's giving like Ally
to the Jewish community so correct me if
I'm wrong because I'm I'm really not a
smart person I think it's like so
important that we always remember that
like is yish giving like Latin because
it's lost yeah and it's like of your in
the sense that it's of your and that
it's lost yes but there are thousands of
lost languages but no Latin is actually
the opposite because well yeah we would
never know that's like a bug out like
why you invented a whole language 30
it's Tower of B it's Babel it's Tower
Babel Babel but Latin is like an is you
know the origin of language so it's kind
of the opposite of Yiddish which is like
two languages put together not like root
okay I got it Yiddish is giving
Creole I don't know a lot about cre oh
creel is French and it's like French
English they speak it in the Caribbean
it's like a combination of like a bunch
of languages yeah cre
language yeah so that's like our
version Haitian yeah yeah
yeah fascinating cool oh my God look at
us being linguistic Queens oh don't get
me started on the word Linguistics you
guys know my story we are linguistic
Queens we always talk about languages
because of Tower of Babble yeah and just
because we're like smart people you know
yeah and language is fascinating
language is
fascinating I mean that should we use
our fascinating language to dive into
the Fast Five sure if there's nothing
else I mean we don't have to like I'm
I'm in no particular rush I guess I'm
technically in a rush to do everything
that I haven't done yet today you
know yeah like I have so much to do plus
the redheads editing I need to get into
the editing Bay I know you kind of
admitted something vulnerable today
yesterday excuse me on the toast that
the redheads is a nonprofit but like
would the redheads ever consider hiring
an editor
like no I'm too protective of it and
I've also thought recently like we kind
of need to hire a social media manager
because I do it and I if you follow us
closely like it comes in waves you know
there's DRS and there's there's rainfall
it's based on your like personal social
events calendar
yeah and so I really should get some
help with that but it's just not that
important to like be on that no no it's
like our social media we figure it out
you know it's it's going it's businga
and it's businga it's fine yeah to get
an editor for the episodes would be good
but it's like I know what I want to take
out I'm just too protective of my people
also even though the red heads is a
non-for-profit we did have an a sponsor
on the episode we do have sponsor like
probably one or two per episode but it
it doesn't cover everyone's Fe you know
so it it sounds like you're just a
poorly run business yes no we're I'm not
in it for the money yeah no but by the
way like the redheads like sell a lot of
merch I think that's worth mentioning
yeah but our sponsor everyone was really
excited it was
carway and carway sent all of the
girlies I already had but they sent
everyone uh non-stick frying pan and
they were obsessed oh my God love that
what's the code
use Code redhe Heads come on guys we
need more sponsors it's a code the test
just give throw the redheads a bone Code
redhe Heads yeah throw the redhe heads
one use code what red red heads read
heads so do make you giggle with the
Reds and by the way I chose your book
none of this is true Lisa Jewel oh my
God I'm so excited I also feel like I
need to check I feel like I had a dream
that Lisa jeel dm'd me but I actually
don't think it was a dream cuz I was
posting a lot about her
books like and why wouldn't she DM me
you know Lisa jeel UK oh yeah all her
books are in the
UK I love UK B she did I'm telling you
no I okay I have to respond to her so
maybe you could get her on the redheads
I know I'm sure a lot of authors would
want to come on the redheads but it's
not really something that we've broached
oh it's not something you're open to no
I'm open to it and I had said a while
ago that if I ever had more bandwidth
and like wanted to take on more one
thing I would want to do is add a
another episode of the redheads like we
do an episode once a month and I would
love to do two a month and the one a
month is the book club and the other one
is like you know if there's an author
that just came out the book just like
book chat yeah or like talking with like
book influencers fellow readers like
just doing a kind of more chitchat
episode that's book Centric but I have
not found the time but still that is
something I'd like to do first of all I
didn't know that that was like a goal of
yours and now it is my mission to help
you achieve that goal so here's what I
post okay what if I join the redheads
but for the other
episode and would that help you how no
like because like I would just
coordinate everything so like yes you
would still have to do the work but like
I would just do it all for you and like
you would just sit down in the chair no
it's the work I I it's it's all right
she doesn't want me involved in her
passions no I mean we invite you on the
redheads every time you have something
to say about the book you're still doing
your lashes by the way I'm just like
it's the same as like if I was sitting
here like combing my hair ha like it's
just I know you do that sometimes but
it's giving like not paying full
attention to your sister who's only has
eyes for you wow I mean I literally just
offered like up like my life to help you
with your passion project and not only
did you turn me down you're now yelling
at me so maybe we should just get into
the past five stories how about
that you are always welcome on an
episode of the redheads when you've read
the book you always join and maybe
you'll join the next one because it's
that's just not what I was talking about
oh I would love to even though it's been
like it's been like a month since I read
the book and you know all those
Thrillers when read so many of them you
forget like what who is who who died who
killed who yeah it's true about The
Thrillers they're kind of a dime a
dozen which it's easy to have like a
good book that you like but it's kind of
hard to Stand Out Among the pack it is
it's you know it's giving
thrill thiller right what books are you
going to read for your
vacation so glad you brought that up
because I was just packing and I told
you guys a story about how I stole the
book from the rental house and like
honestly like ever since I said said it
on the toast I wish I didn't say it cuz
like I literally stole like I admitted
to thievery um but I'm not packing a
checked bags so like I have to be really
really tight and like I just would
prefer to bring just my Kindle than my
Kindle and my stolen book I think my
stolen book will remain at home for me
and I bought like I'm going to buy like
a dumb romance book because I'm going to
be on the beach with like a bunch of
friends I probably won't even read that
much I'll be drinking like it's not that
it's not that kind of trip but for the
plane ride like maybe it's it's on a
serious reading trip like don't worry
yeah but Jackie this is the kind of
stuff we talk about if you'd let me join
the redheads for the second episode okay
I will oh you want to be on the second
episode that's what I was saying like I
don't want to be a redhead like you guys
saw a great thing going on I thought you
were offering to join the redheads book
club no no that's like handled but for
this second episode like I could kind of
just be like your assistant almost like
where I would like we we could come up
with ideas and like I would find the
authors to interview or influencers and
I would set it all up and you would just
have to sit down and then I would edit
too oh my God that's so nice would you
want to be on camera like would you want
to be on the show oh I'm sorry you
thought I was just like no at first I
thought you want to be on oh you don't
want me to be on the you want me to do
all the work oh my God this is
literally insane this is insane first
first I thought you wanted to be on the
book club Then I then you want to be on
the second episode then it started to
sound like you wanted to be my
producer no I'm just saying like I like
this is something you want to do but you
don't have the bandwidth for everything
involved so I'll do like I'll be we'll
do it together but like I'll do
everything like that's required you know
what I'm s just an episode of the
toast no but like we would interview
authors wiers who like to read we would
just maybe have like episodes where we
talk just about
books yeah okay okay so we would be
doing it
together okay you know what like I
really wish I didn't offer because
you're making like you're making fun of
me now no I'm not you just
misrepresented the idea in so many
different ways I'm going back to
brushing my eyebrows okay and your
eyelashes um okay just think about it
okay I actually I will think about it
lard and I do hope that in the next few
months I'm able to take on more you know
things I really think it's time we take
the redheads to the next level and I
think I have to get involved like for
real because we have weirdly like so
much influence when it comes to reading
books like we need to be able to Brand
around that you know yeah I do also get
some like inbound emails to the redheads
email that are like interesting that I
don't even respond
to or like like you like that's what I'm
saying like you're managing the brand
and like no offense like that's why you
are where you are like you're just too
booked and busy like Mom of two
full-time
working mom like I get it let me help
it's true the brand could go to the next
level like we should become hello
sunshine and right or like okay not
hello sunshine like let's be real but
like a Jenna Bush Hager Vibe you know
okay she's literally just as
big okay sorry like um like an Oprah
yeah like similar to Oprah Reese Jenna
red red the name on everybody's lips no
I I really like we your head dad and
that is goals like redheads production
company right let me help you okay we'll
strategize I like thank I appreciate
your persistence you've got the
job great you're high start on Monday no
it's a holiday and we appreciate on
Tuesday start on
Tuesday okay now we can get into the
stories that are storying on this day of
THS without further Ado here are the
fast Liv stories that you need to know
and the fast five stories that you need
to know are brought to you by a new show
on Netflix it is called the trust a game
of greed 11 strangers are given a
quarter of a million dollars to split
evenly will they take their fair share
or will the Allure of more money cause
them to vote each other out to keep more
for themselves it's the ultimate test of
human nature as greed and mistrust
threaten to destroy even the strongest
of relationships in The game everyone
starts as winners and they can all leave
as winners if they choose to share I
just know if I was on this show like my
God everybody would be going home with
nothing cuz I would ruin it for everyone
like I'm a greedy person and I also am
just very mistrusting like I just don't
believe that this group of people would
like have my best interest at heart so
the show is premiering on Netflix it's a
new competition Series where 11
strangers are being offered a quarter of
a million dollars the choice is there as
it's the ultimate test of good verse
greed the players start as winners the
cast is super diverse they come from all
different walks of life so it's a great
wide set of people all from different
socioeconomic backgrounds which
obviously like makes it more interesting
because some people might really need
the money this might not be considered a
lot of money to some of the people um it
sounds like a really great show I can't
wait to watch the trust a game of greed
which is now streaming only on Netflix
yeah that's right the game the show was
called the trust a game of greed and it
is streaming now only on Netflix today's
episode is also brought to you by
betterhelp around the new year we can
get obsessed with how to change
ourselves instead of just expanding on
what we're already doing right maybe you
finally organized one part of your space
and you want to tackle another maybe
you're taking your supplements every
morning and now you want to actually eat
breakfast too therapy can help you find
your strengths so you can ditch the
extreme resolutions and make changes
that really stick so if you're thinking
of starting therapy give better help a
try the new year is always a great time
to get into a good therapy Groove if
you've never tried therapy or if you're
you know not been super committed to It
New Year New You great time of year and
better help is an amazing resource
because it's done entirely online it's
designed to be convenient flexible and
suited to your schedule just fill out a
brief questionnaire get match with a
licensed therapist and of course you can
switch therapist at any time for no
additional charge which is what I think
a lot of people's favorite part of
better help is cuz one of the most
awkward things about therapy traditional
therapy is you know the awkwardness of
it it's very common not to jive with the
first therapist that you meet and then
having to call and cancel and change can
be so weird better help totally gets it
super easy to change it's very common
it's not a big deal if the first person
you're matched with doesn't you know
work out personality wise they will help
you change switch therapists at any time
for no charge you can also um talk to a
therapist however You' like whether text
video chat phone call Etc so celebrate
the progress you've already made and
visit betterhelp.com toast to get 10%
off your first month today that's
betterhelp
hp.com toast betterhelp.com
thank you la you're welcome okay our
first story in no in order of no
importance I would say I would say these
are five equally important stories love
and equally un important love John meany
and Olivia mun make their red carpet
debut after three years together so John
mlan and Olivia m are red carpet
official finally I had no idea that they
weren't yet they literally have a child
together I didn't know like we were
waiting no they're like chies so
polarizing it's insane we were waiting
to check red carpet off the list but
they attended the Academy of Motion
Picture arts and scientists 14th
Governor's award in LA and they looked
unreal for a first she looked gorina
vagina Yeah by they I mean she because I
don't look at the man she looked amazing
no shook by that the hair love no the
everything I guess the dress could use
Este steam now that I'm I was really
just looking at her there are people
who's like this is their Roman Empire
you know they were obsessed with John
meany and Anna tendler like there are
some people who can't even look at these
two like it's so it runs so deep and
while I you know respect that I'm not a
part of that group of people like I
don't care um but it's really crazy how
like they these to like hide out like
they're considered so controversial it's
so dumb I feel like once it's been a few
years and you have a child especially
once you have a child it's like Tabby
laasa yeah know I think a lot of people
get really stuck on the fact that he was
with anamarie tendler for so many years
and they never had a baby and then like
the second he broke up with her he had a
baby with Olivia man like that day no
it's not it's not like the best of human
behavior no but it's what happened and I
will say I've never been like a joh m
right no it's so
common I've never been a John meany fan
I don't think I've actually ever even
seen his comedy but once he became like
Public Enemy Number One I found him to
be a lot more interesting than like the
guy who just everybody loved like it's
who cares but once like people started
to hate him I was like oh I think there
might be more to this complex fella and
I watched his special um called I think
it's called Baby J it's the most recent
special yeah me too where he talks about
he had an insane addiction and he talks
about you know going from being this you
know Hollywood sweetheart where who
everybody loved couldn't do anything
wrong to then becoming you know
controversial Public Enemy Number One so
we actually had like a lot of
interesting things to talk about and I
thought it was an excellent special I
found myself like cackling many times
highly recommend I watched it I don't
remember feeling that way but also you
recap the entire thing likeability is a
prison yeah you would recap the entire
thing before I watched it so there was
like nothing new for me that's why I
don't like the when you're trying to
recap the crown today SL yesterday I
just didn't want to hear your POV
because then it's like why do I need to
watch cuz I agree no for sure so I'll
just shut the up is what you're
saying I would say to hold off until
I've caught up with
you shut the up until further
notice I got it
okay anyways they were looking great the
crazy thing about Olivia man to me is
Aaron roders yeah no for by the way the
craziest thing about Olivia man to me is
wag oh and not in the Aaron Rogers way
yeah no oh she was a wag who was a
co-owner in wag yeah yeah yeah yeah not
being like a wife and girlfriend of
professional athletes she was like one
of the founders of that dog walking app
wag and she was like in all the
commercials and it's like everyone was
just like is that Olivia m or someone
who looks like her literally literally
also the craziest thing about Olivia man
to me is Aaron roders and the craziest
thing about Olivia man and Aaron Rogers
to me is like the Rogers Family Feud and
the craziest thing is that Jordan Rogers
and JoJo Fletcher are related to Aaron
Rogers and they're all on TV every
single day and they don't talk to each
other every day they are always hosting
something okay they they host like
couple shows and home shows and
yeah the craziest thing and he's on SEC
Sports okay that was like a while ago I
don't know if he's still on I feel like
the craziest thing about Olivia mun is
that her and Aaron Rogers like didn't
make it but Jojo and Jordan did you know
and I feel like at the time it was like
Olivia mun and Aaron Rogers were
together for so long there were this
like it couple in Hollywood and they
Jordan and Jojo I feel like they like
look down on as like this like trash
reality TV show it's like all for money
and fame and greed and now they're like
happily married and Olivia m and Aaron
Rogers like are not yeah Margot was
saying the other day that the Rogers
Family Feud is her Roman Empire and
that's a really good one it's a really
good one like like what the
happened that these people cannot talk
no but like the whole family does talk
except not to Aaron I know what
happened I don't know it's got to be big
yeah but I have to say if you're like
the one person who's on the outs with
your entire family like your entire
family still talks but not to you and
you don't talk to your entire family you
are the problem like whatever happened
you up I agree especially cuz
from what we've seen of his family like
they're very Ling and they're very close
and they're like the Rogers boys mhm
there's another one Luke yeah it's not
like you're on the ANS with your family
but the rest of the family doesn't get
along either and it's all kind of it's
not like this toxic family where nobody
talks to each other yeah it seems very
loving and you know home home is where
the heart is not Homestead home is where
the heart is it's so true you know like
flannels who could forget
flannels
fireplaces yeah yeah no I know what
you're saying but I get it I get it it's
like cozy family Vibes no I get it I get
it some of the best Vibes out there
right right no I get it so anyways
they're red carpet official as if you
needed that too and I'm no by the way I
didn't know I needed that but I
did I I agree it did something for me
yeah are you ready for our next story
mhm a little casting news which is some
of my favorite kind of news oh yeah
Selena Gomez will be playing Linda ronat
in a new biopic so Selena Gomez will
play Linda ronat in an upcoming biopic
variety has confirmed the pop singer
teased the role Tuesday night by posting
a picture of Linda's 2013 Memoir called
called Simple dreams the music I know I
the music biopic is currently in
pre-production with producers including
her manager Linda's manager who also
prod a doc produced a documentary about
her no other casting has been announced
I mean Selen is like Loki is like an
actress she's like known as a pop star
but like she's literally an actress
that's what I was going to say I think
one of the things Selena Gomez does many
things some better than others and I
think one thing that she does best of
all is act I think she's a very good
actress she's very good and only murders
in The Bu building Woody Allen like
loves her cuz she's a very good actress
and I think not only is she talented
enough but they do look alike and people
have said that they look alike they are
also both of Mexican descent I think
this is an absolutely perfect casting I
agree and I like that she like I've
never been like an enormous fan of her
music um and so I like that she's
clearly for the time being focusing on
acting only murderers Golden Globe Emy
nominated um and I think that this is a
great next move for her because only
murders in the building while it's like
a Hulu show whatever it's very
prestigious like it's not like just
being on any she said the Golden Globes
she not only that but like Martin schw
and Steve Martin like two of the
greatest comedians literally of our time
Merill Streep Paul R it's not just any
TV show so it's like her being on like
the most elite it's like what probably I
think it's in the last like 10 years the
most critically like the highest
critically rated show in terms of like
ratings and stuff so it's it's really
Supreme and so her doing a movie Next
and having it be like a musical one is
very smart I think this is actually very
good management and like decision-
making on Selena Gomez's behalf I agree
what does Linda rodad sing she sings
Heart Like a Wheel and simple dreams
those were her albums I don't know um I
like her name rolls off the tongue Linda
Roat but I couldn't really tell you who
she is she also sounds
Jewish okay here's her like number hold
on here's her number one
[Music]
song look
at
man oh it's a
duet
okay not for me and I and I don't know
it
so
Selena good
luck it's I I think it could be very
very good no notes on this casting yeah
I think it's a good call I do like I
don't know Linda Rona but I imagine this
is like very interesting to a lot of
people like who either grew up with her
or were a fan of for music cuz I I love
when a celebrity is being depicted in a
fil and like the casting begins like how
long did we talk about
Elvis yeah and then we had Freddy
Mercury and we had Elton John like I
love movies like that y yep are you
ready for our next story speaking of
actors I think yeah a new report says
that cruel and manipulative Matthew
Perry lied about his sobriety before his
death his pal say Okay literally today
like five stories came out like
slanderous against Matthew Perry yeah
Matthew Perry alleged she was clean and
sober for 19 months leading up to his
shocking death however a new report
claims that this wasn't the case the
friend star who shot to Global Fame
after landing the role of chanler Bing
on the hit sitcom was found unresponsive
in a hot tub in La at his home on
October 28th friends who saw the actor
near the end of his life insists that
Matthew who spoke openly about his
lifelong struggles with addiction was
sober and in a good place however three
sources tell Us Weekly that's not true
they said Matthew's talk about being
sober while promoting his 2022 Memoir
was a lie they said in a report
published Wednesday he wanted to sell
books everything was crafted and
manipulated the truth wasn't important
The Source also told the outlet
apparently he crashed his Aston Martin
many times while high noting that the
alleged accidents happened during a time
that Perry claimed to be sober he just
damaged the car and no one was hurt but
he did not consider that he could have
killed someone the sours alleged that
Perry would use the Celeb dating app Ria
to meet young women who would bring him
drugs he would do the face yeah they
said he would do the FaceTime thing and
get to know them then it would be be
like let's hang out and he would say to
come to his house he wasn't out in
public anymore that's how he snuck
things past people addicts are smart and
Matthew was brilliant as previously
reported an autopsy determined that
Matthew died from acute effects of
ketamine while with contributing factors
listed as drowning coronary artery
disease and
buprenorphine effects the thing is like
I just read Matthew Perry's book and
like I feel like he would cite examples
where he lied about being so sober for
like many long periods of time and for
different like work commitments and
stuff so if when he was promoting this
book he wasn't sober like I don't think
that's necessarily like inous yeah or
like duplicitous of him like he made it
abundantly clear in the book like he
knows how to get sober he doesn't know
how to stay sober like he knows exactly
what to do when it's time to detox in
the most like painless you know for the
most part way um it's a lifelong
struggle for him he's never really going
to figure it out so like if he had
slipped I don't know to me that doesn't
like undo everything he said in the book
I actually I feel like it's like a more
authentic it makes it makes everything
in his book feel even
more relevant yeah Also regarding the
ketamine I think a lot of people were
confused because um ketamine infusions
are used to treat depression and drug
addiction however the medical examiner
had noted that the amount found in his
system could not have been from his
final infusion treatment a week and a
half before his death ketamine's half
life is only 3 to four hours and the
amount found in his system was
equivalent to the general anesthesia
given to surgical patients so it was an
abuse of ketamine right
likely
and right and it's possible like he
didn't take enough to like kill himself
but because he was in a hot tub he drown
right right and so compounded it was
fatal for him and so yes this is
different from the Matthew that we
thought he was at the end of his life
but like no Jackie if you read the book
it's not like he said like I'm sober now
for life like it's literally a
day-by-day thing
yeah I don't know but he's passed now it
just no to come out and like poly like
be a source to US Weekly like you're
disgusting yeah it just feels
like achy to hear like these personal
details about him when he's passed like
let him rest what's the point yeah yeah
no I didn't like this at all especially
I feel like fiercely defensive of M
Matthew Perry ever since I read his book
like it was so good reading someone's
book will do that to you oh my god do
you know how many times literally last
night I referenced Josh peek's book
because it was like so full of just
goodness like really I I find it
relevant to bring up in so many
different conversations if I'm talking
about child actors Josh P if I'm talking
about weit Josh pek if I'm talking about
drug addiction Josh pek if I'm like
literally anything I it's one of the
best books I literally need to read it
like next oh and he's like funny too no
I know I I like it was on my want to
read but then it just just kind of got
pushed down but like I'm going to read
that this month I'm going to put it back
at the top of my list no like Mom he was
raised by a single mom he was raised by
single mom and like she's really a main
character and I had read it around the
same time that I read uh Janette mcc's
book which you know they're so similar
child actors from Nickelodeon um but she
was really
like put out by her mother and really
used by her mother and then after her
book I read Josh's and Josh just loved
his mom so much and she would have done
anything for him and all he it like the
acting was so his idea like he begged
his mom and she dragged him around town
like it was just so so the opposite of
Janette MCC and he like the way he wrote
about his mom was just so it was you're
going to love it I seriously can't wait
I might start that tonight oh nope I
have to edit the redheads damn passion
strikes again passion strikes again but
maybe tonight as in Thursday night
because it's Thursday oh BL I like what
you did there okay are you ready for our
next story
no I didn't think you were you really
didn't look ready I didn't want to say
anything but that's so rude our next
story is brought to you by Squarespace
the all-in-one website platform for
entrepreneurs to stand out and succeed
online whether you're just starting out
or managing a growing brand Squarespace
makes it easy to create a beautiful
website engage with your audience and
sell anything from podcasts products to
content to time all in one place and all
on your terms so whatever your reasoning
is for creating a website whether you
want to have a website made or you want
to revamp your website you feel like
it's a little dated the product features
at Squarespace cover the gamut of really
anything you could possibly need they
have asset libraries you can sell custom
merch you can sell your products in the
online store their website templates are
super flexible so you can get started
with one of their professional templates
with designs for every category in use
case and then just customize your look
update your content and add features
that fit your unique needs you can also
host video content on Squarespace
websites so if you're like a
videographer and you want to showcase
your portfolio some of your previous
work you can host video content organize
your video library showcase your content
online in beautiful pages and sell
access to your videos with member areas
also a point of sale so if you have an
e-commerce website and you want to sell
in person you can do that by connecting
a square reader to the Squarespace app
and that'll keep all of your inperson
and online orders inventory and customer
data in sync with one another so head to
squarespace.com you'll get a free trial
and when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com toast to save 10% off
your first purchase of a website or a
domain at squarespace.com toast to save
10% off your first purchase of a website
or a
domain great thank you wel our next
story is that Robert dairo thought his
name was called at the Golden Globes
when Robert Downey Jr won oh no yep
Robert de daos
deoo his ears definitely perked up when
he heard his name first announced as the
winner of the 2024 Golden Globe for best
supporting actor in a motion picture um
a second later however it was Robert
Downey Jr making his way to the stage
but such are the risks of being an actor
named Robert who starred in one of the
most acclaimed films of the year it's
giving album of the year goes
to Random Access Memory not read by
Taylor Swift oh I didn't know that was
have you ever seen that video oh my God
okay she was nominated for album of the
year for red and they have all the faces
on of the nominees like up in little
squares and they say the album of the
year goes to and the person really
really like lingered on the
r and her you see her in the box and her
whole team they're like oh and random
access memory you have to watch it it's
so awkward that is very awkward and it's
crazy that those things even happen to
Robert dairo no but it actually makes
sense I I didn't I didn't put together
that Robert dairo and Robert Johny Jr
have the same first name even as I just
said it right now like it didn't compute
yeah and it's Robert D
oh so true this is two days in a row
talking about Robert dairo actually
three days because I think on on Monday
or Tuesday we talked about the joke that
yeah and then Wednesday yeah we talked
about him at Jennifer Lawrence's wedding
this is our Robert daero
streak do you think we should keep it
going like try and bring him up on
Friday I think so what's your favorite
Robert dairo movie and why is it the
intern oh it's the intern no I know the
intern is the most amazing movie I
completely agree and I want to think the
folks is similar the same but different
The Internship I knew you were going to
say that the intern is better I'm sorry
I love them both so much like equally
but
differently and I'm just so grateful for
movies made about interns no I by the
way should we hire an
intern and like film it and follow him
or her around and call it the intern
yeah no the intern with Robert aniro and
an hathway like is the best movie of all
time and I want to thank the folks at e
for always having it as like their movie
of the day like it's on cable 45 times a
week it's the best it's so amazing of
course Nancy Meyers slays oh my God
that's such an underrated Nancy Meers
movie because it's like so not her vibe
like and there's no like Central home
where everyone congregating there is
it's halfway townhouse but it's like not
even Chic no but it's not home and
hearth over there it's very like my
husband she does homestead my husband's
cheating yeah no I actually like I don't
like that as for Nancy Myers like it's a
good movie I like the movie but like I
don't like it for Nancy Myers
yeah she could do better you know no but
it's really good the movie is
amazing so Robert dairo has the same
name as Robert Downey Jr and that was
confusing for him and I understand why
it would be yeah do you think like he
cares like do you think he got really
excited that he was about to win a
Golden Globe like or no I don't think so
like at that point but it's worth noting
that he's been nominated 10 times and
only won once in 1981 so it's been 30
years wait I read something today and I
read I saw it in a Tik Tok apparently
like there's like big drama with Bradley
Cooper and Killian
Murphy Killian is Oppenheimer so
apparently like Bradley Cooper has been
nominated for a Golden Globe like 30
times and has never won
and this movie Maestro is like this big
passion project of his he's been working
on it for six years and like he's like
wanting to make it like his big moment
his big thing like he wants to win all
the awards it's like this is really
important to him and he did that variety
actors and actors um thing with Emma
Stone and talked about like you know he
really respected how you know long she
worked on the role and he and he worked
on his role and he like made a little
slight towards Killian Murphy who I
believe um did not spend like a lot of
time prepping for Oppenheimer in the
sense that he didn't have the role
booked for six years before he actually
got to work you know so apparently they
like have this beef according to this
dumb Tik Tok that I read and when the
best actor in a drama category came
obviously they both were nominated and
Killian won and like that it was even
more layered that Killian
won but I feel like Killian doesn't even
care and like Bradley's fighting with
himself no that's exactly what I'm
feeling like like okay Bradley
Killian doesn't even know your name like
she's not talking about you Killian's
like you know Lions don't lose sleep
over the whatever of sheep opinions of
sheep right and Trash Talk of sheep and
subtle wearing big prosthetic noses yeah
but I think the big one is the Oscar so
let's see what happens there but like I
don't know much but I know that no one's
talking about Bradley Cooper's movie mro
like nobody cares not a soul and and I
have to wonder
why yeah what platform is it on
Netflix it's not in the theaters I don't
know but there was like no like Big
Marketing it was on Netflix that's a
good point because we were just looking
it up like the the only thing I really
heard about the movie was the nose drama
which like wasn't overwhelmingly
positive for him so like I didn't feel
like there was like a coordinated
marketing campaign I didn't see like
buses or Billboards like no one's
talking about it because like they gave
us nothing to talk about yeah it's on
Netflix
yeah I'm good no I'm definitely good
yeah no if I was like really wanting
stuff to watch it maybe I would find
want to watch it but I've my plate is
full my cup runneth over she can't even
get two episodes of redheads down a
month like what do you guys expect right
I haven't watched the crown I haven't
watched Southern CH I haven't watched
Salt Lake City I haven't watched Beverly
Hills like mro is all the way down there
haven't much bar to take yeah I haven't
watch Matilda the Musical like that's
insane oh that's disgusting of you
disgusting like when I saw the trailer
for it I was so excited and I don't even
know if it's I don't know anything about
it it like did it make waves here in the
states no it didn't but it looks so
freaking cute yeah so yeah I have my
priorities in order that you do that you
do are you ready for our fifth and final
story yes about our Queen Amy Schumer
unveiling a topless selfie with an extra
40 lb she says Amy Schumer is feeling
pretty at all s the comedian shared a
topless photo celebrating her body on
January 7th posting the partially nude
mirror selfie on her Instagram story
showed Amy smiling while raising her
hand in the air she posed in front of
the glass walls of her shower she said
still got it and then underneath she
wrote that 40 extra pounds I just want
to say like she's funny like this is a
funny thing to do and I know she's like
poking fun at her weight but I actually
thought she looked like bomb in the
photo like really tight and right like I
didn't even see cellulite like tight and
right yeah tight and right and I'm sorry
like every time I like go to Amy
Schumer's social media or like I watch
something that she did like I'm sorry
she's funny I feel like people rail on
her a lot she's funny she is funny I
feel like she suffered from like
overexposure and she she got so big so
fast because she was really so funny
like you know there's no bigger Amy
Schumer fan on the planet than Dana and
it is actually one of my career goals in
addition to doing a second episode of
the redheads a month to meet Amy Schumer
like on a professional level
as like a a peer in a way and tell her
that that little girl that she sees at
all of her shows is my best friend and
she's very normal yeah for sure um but
you're right like her career trajectory
was so unorthodox like she shot to a
level of Fame so fast that female
comedians just like don't get and she
was kind of like a Matt rif in a sense
um but once you know she got shown her
work got shown to like a mass audience
people were like wow she really is funny
and she got even bigger Matt Rice's
having like the oppos opposite effect
like you got this big Netflix special
and like people aren't into it um and
then it was like bus Club another club
Bus Madison Square Garden selling out
Arenas movie movie movie and I think it
got to be by the time she did that movie
with Goldie
Han she should have stopped right before
that yeah yeah just cuz you do a lot of
things like the quality isn't always
there but you know the studio wants you
and so I think it's been up and down but
at her core she's an extremely funny
person like train rck and I feel pretty
are two of the funniest movies of our
time I feel you know I I literally can't
talk about the movie I feel pretty like
it's literally my life yeah it is like I
I had never and I feel like I've said
this on the toes now like three or four
times I have never walked into a movie
and like seen my life on screen like it
was crazy and I remember going with
Margot and she like didn't get it I'm
like oh my God you suck like cuz she
just doesn't have like these problems
that I have and she was like no it was
like funny and cute but like she didn't
walk out like emphatic like me yeah that
movie was brilliant it doesn't
get us as much credit as um train W cuz
cuz train wreck was so good but I'm
sorry I feel pretty like is amazing it
is amazing I need we should add it
that's a good for the content list yes
even though a Feelgood film it's funny
the content list is dead in the water
right right because we referenced it
once on our trip
yeah but that's a good family movie for
you know mature adults
yeah it's also just like it's got a
great message it has a great
message no and like when Amy hits her
head and then like enters this dystopian
utopian universe that's how I live my
life like it's just it's so good yeah
anyways uh also note about her selfie is
that her bathroom is gorgeous yes yes
Amy lives on the upper west side I
believe
um Kim Kardashian went to her apartment
on up yes Amy Shir is also extremely
rich and I'm happy for her and I assume
that means she has nice things
yeah yeah I like the style it's very big
and she has a
Toto ooh looks like a claw foot tub and
a towel drying rack o she uses Cetaphil
Rel I saw the Cetaphil I saw the
Cetaphil which is so Amy shimer yeah no
it was just um very
cute so that is our
show for Thursday for today for today my
favorite day which is Thursday it's the
best today tomorrow being Friday's
episode is going to be the same as this
you know little Audio Only might be out
later in the day because I'm going to be
on like different Mexican time zone I
actually don't even know what time it's
going to be so it's going to be weird um
so stay tuned for that we love you all
so much thank you so much for listening
to the joia morning show we deliver the
fast stories need to know every Monday
Friday and new on YouTube pleas this
video thumbs
up a beautiful stunning and wickedly
talented we are have an amazing Thursday
and we'll see you on the next one love
you bye love you
bye